hi welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and this is our menu
breakdown yes the movie's been out for a
minute and yes I made a single short
about it and we decided a new Rockstar
to hell why didn't we break this down
earlier luckily I went to the West Coast
Premiere followed by the Q a with
producer Betsy coach and some of the
cast along with being a bit of a foodie
myself I'm not I decided to break down
this movie for you with an in-depth and
unheard of behind the scenes and really
getting into the food and Chef Julian
slowik like the menu and prepare for you
a series of courses in over the next 15
minutes or so probably less you will
ingest culinary art authenticity
dedication and one of the highest
demanded forms of Digital entertainment
Easter egg breakdowns let's begin
chapter one the literal menu one of the
biggest takeaways from this film was the
literal menu and the lore behind it and
don't act like that cheeseburger wasn't
the finest damn cheeseburger you ever
done saw the food consultant was none
other than Chef's Table Dominic kren who
is the first and only woman in America
to win three Michelin stars at a
restaurant which is famous for its 400
ahead meals I could never afford it she
designed the dishes and the director
Mark myloyd only requested Julia dishes
had to be spectacular but dead which
plays not only physically the oysters
the scallops what have you but each meal
though beautiful was missing the love
and life put into it which is the core
of the entire movie you think it's a
disconnect in microaggressions between
chefs and their diners but it's really
losing yourself entirely to satisfy
others like Tyler says the menu is a
concept slowik is telling a story the
story of the menu lies in classism the
inequality between the artist and the
consumer where the artists will
painstakingly create something that
could consume them whole mentally or
physically it's like their most prized
Obsession being taken for granted Julian
slowik makes Divine pieces for people
who don't enjoy it who don't deserve it
and who don't recognize its true meaning
Dominic krenz said in an interview the
film also points at the angel investor
and the balance of power between the
artists and those who fund their work we
have to rebalance things the money is
not better than the talent and the money
and the talent should be more equal so
we get into that physically with the
meals in my opinion the story behind The
food doesn't start until the first
course which is the island the man
fishing for scallops earlier was a clear
knock along with the food being found
around the island the resources the
island offers is endless the entire
ecosystem is at our disposal to use with
it what we will but never recognize
we're nothing without it we don't really
think about each grain herb or natural
ingredient we use and how meaningless we
are but how important it is a reflection
to how the movie will end but also
another look at the artist and the
consumer the artist being the ecosystem
and us as the consumer and how we take
it all for granted the second course is
the breadless bread plate which is my
favorite I'm an oblivious person
absolutely always room for error on my
part and this was a smack in the face
some would say bread is one of the most
important things in history bread is the
oldest food that doesn't require us
hunting like slowex says bread reached
the poor from ancient Greek times to
Christianity red at one point was made
with the simple ingredients and digested
by the common man it's literally for the
Common Man and these folks they are rich
they don't know what it's like to be a
common man therefore they get no bread
but they can't have the side dishes that
is until later in the movie Margot
indeed does give bread the common woman
I believe so one of us one of us I'm
poor help me I'm poor the third course
house smoke breast chicken thigh al
pastor along with tortillas made with
heirloom Masa AKA memory the meal is
meant to invoke a memory and
unfortunately Julian slowik's memory is
the time his dad almost killed his mom
in front of him as a child and he
stabbed him in the thigh with scissors
to get him to stop he hopes this course
evokes memories in everyone and it does
when images of the guests infidelities
embezzlements and downfalls are etched
into their tortillas where his dad was
an alcoholic and abusive the esteemed
Rich guest dining all conducted just bad
rich people behavior all guests he
served in one way or another and time or
craft all reminders of why he lost his
love and cooking by serving rich people
who just don't care you start to forget
why you even started this is when the
story behind the menu on the rich and
the poor begins blending with slowik
losing his Joy behind his craft the
fourth course the mess a turn of events
for sure sous chef Jeremy Louden has
always looked up to Julian slowik Jeremy
has forsaken everything to achieve his
goals and turns out the goals end just
there at Hawthorne because ultimately
he'll never be great he'll never be
Julian it was always an endless Chase
never caught even when everything is
perfect everyone loves it you'll never
avoid the mess you make like slowik says
you'll lose your sanity giving
everything you have to please people you
never know another nod to Art in the
consumer but also slowx life Dominic
Karen said they touch on mental illness
a bit and this is probably the exact
moment she says our industry is one of
the number one Industries in terms of
mental health issues suicide alcoholism
drugs these are the workers that put
their whole selves into making something
that is beautiful and the pressure from
the outside is immense which ties up
Jeremy's unfortunate succession to the
mess the fifth course the palate
cleanser and I mean after the mess yeah
we all need a palette cleanser they
indeed get their own personal version of
a palette cleanser the truth each of
them are ingredients to the meal and the
meal doesn't work without them Lillian
and Phil the food critic doesn't even
recognize the damage she's done to
fellow chefs in their restaurants
getting them shut down based on her own
personal experience a fake creative
destroying art the ego on her and
Richard the rich died in the Hawthorne
11 times no one should be able to afford
that they can't even name a single dish
they had the last time they were there
after I told you how important the craft
is to Julian you understand why that's
so rude Doug Barrack's employees
embezzling money the finance Bros are a
symbol of Despicable big money High
earning accountants and of course they
work for Doug Barrick very basically
owns Julian as his angel investor he is
credited with taking the love out of
cooking for Julian by basically owning
him and creating a hierarchy between the
investor and the artist Tyler his
obsession with Julian he's completely
entitled and willing to kill Margot just
to dine at Hawthorne he not only had the
money but the audacity he also didn't
obey the rules he took pictures of the
food when they strictly told him not to
the movie star and his poor assistant
now it's simple to understand why Rich
movie star and nepotistic baby would
fall under Julian's wrath but simply
George Diaz wasted Julian's time as Dr
sunshine and the strict frustration from
losing that one day was so funny and
grounded enough to get him killed the
sixth course man's Folly this course was
created and introduced by sous chef
Catherine inspired by the time Julian
tried to have sex with her and persisted
when she said no he then ignored her for
eight months because he's the star he's
the man clearly a comment on The
Culinary industry with harassment and
sexism but also each man is given the
opportunity to escape off the island
bidding farewell to their female Corner
Parts their Partners wives colleagues
it's truly insane how quick they abandon
them now Foley means a lack Good Sense
foolishness and the true foolishness was
believing they could really Escape that
they had control over the situation the
impending doom that is their fate is
coming no matter how far they get on the
island how great they are at hiding
their time has come it's out of their
hands the final course s'mores like
people dining at Hawthorne tonight
s'mores is how Julian says the most
offensive assault on the human palette
ever contrived they are the s'mores as
you normally do you roasts more so these
guests are about to get roasted the
roast is contrived in a cleansing and to
be born Anew it's horribly artistic but
also interesting to see all these people
bask in their finale and with that the
story has been told the menu Works once
everyone dies the full story the meaning
behind the menu these people represent
the ruining behind Julian's art and now
they get to die with it
farewell taking care of yourself is
important so good thing geology makes it
easy to do geology is a 16-time
award-winning personalized skin care
company recognizing hypebeast birdie
Men's Health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews you can't get that anywhere else
just take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz in geology will create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
customized just for you with the
ingredients that our dermatologist
tested proven to work and personalize to
your needs because that's very important
don't just use anything off the shelf
for Hair Care geology's got
strengthening shampoo and conditioner
and co-wash which will transform your
routine and deliver the best hair for
your life it extends the time between
washes and replaces the need for so many
products so you wash your hair less and
save more money they also offer body
washes and deodorants that are free of
harsh ingredients and smell great like I
said before you don't want pimples on
your pits for skin care they have you
covered from all angles fight acne
reduce oiliness oiliness oil-ness
oiliness oiliness fight acne reduce
oiliness prevent wrinkles combat darker
puffy under eyes have smoother hydrated
skin and Target signs of aging guys
you're not getting any younger their
daily personalized skincare routine
comes with two face washes morning face
cream retinal night cream eye cream and
right now for a limited time you can get
a five piece trial set for only 15 if
you use the code rockstar70 at checkout
that's over 150 dollars a product for
just fifteen dollars that's
on top of that you can take an
additional 30 bonus offer on one of
their brand new skin hair and body
products of your choice when you add it
to your trial to get started just click
the link in the description below get on
it
chapter 2 behind the characters there's
a ton of great characters and I want to
dive into the idea behind them their
motivations and how they're much needed
characters for the story additionally I
like to add the mark Miley the director
casted the entire background staff and
it was a mandatory they all had
previously worked in the restaurant
industry he said I didn't want anybody
who worked in the industry to watch this
film and go well that's not right they
shouldn't be doing that and I think
that's just really neat let's also begin
with Julian slowing Dominic kren worked
really closely with Ray fines giving him
pointers he said I spent a lot of time
working with Ray and I reminded him that
he was the one in charge the director of
the symphony your confidence and your
intensity is essential I showed him how
to walk into the kitchen how your eyes
have to be everywhere so that you can
see what's cooking what's going on in
the pantry what's going on in the dining
room it's just so intense and you see
that when he takes over the role he's a
complex character slowik LED his
obsession with perfection and his craft
turn him into a maniac he completely
succumbed to the pressure and lifestyle
of being a successful chef and
recognizing that people you spend
catering to aren't really worth catering
to he decides to go out in Flames he's
the god of the kitchen and the food is
the a religion Margot played by Anya
Taylor Joy is the voice of reason
everyone was a part of the menu but her
so her reactions are as grounded as ours
Margo is the common man she's a sex
worker hired by Tyler to unknowingly die
that evening and like slow wake she once
enjoyed the job but now hates it Anya
Taylor Joy says it best Margo's an
enigma and she's supposed to be the
director also noted that Margo had some
of the least amount of dialogue she
constantly lived in the reaction and
planning to get out I personally believe
she's great at reading people which is
why she finds a way of escaping at the
End by playing into slowing sadness Elsa
played by Hong Chao the maitre d but
also Julian slowik's number one disciple
after witnessing Julian you would assume
his other half would be just as intense
as he is and you're right imagine
working in the kitchen and the front of
the restaurant catering to the guests at
Hawthorne under Julian's Reign you must
be a firm believer and follower in
anything that man says Elsa literally
does Elsa never gets a monologue she
never expresses why she started
following slowly nothing which makes her
my favorite character her motivation is
completely chef slowik and what he
requests minor characters like Anne
Richard's wife really stood out to me as
well she's not necessarily as bad as her
husband and throughout the movie if she
wasn't drinking she was shoving her
feelings deep down what I did like was
the rest of the staff noticing and
acknowledging the tortilla with the
infidelities and Elsa cutting off his
ring finger and giving her the ring it's
like they knew she was trapped in needed
freedom but maybe a little nudge she's
also the first to Usher Margot to escape
and leave them on their own she
recognized Margo wasn't like them she
had a sincere character Arc that could
easily go unnoticed and when she finally
succumbed to death in the end he was
ready chapter 3 the Easter egg there was
a lot of room for improv which is
unheard of in movies like this one
improvised moment was Julian sloakes
Taco Tuesday but the assistant George
Diaz had the most most of their banter
was improvised along with this I wrote a
negative recommendation to Sony
I know you see seed me on it and this
you know it's it's the emoji for me
George Diaz's character is also based on
Steven Seagal which is sad Julian's
reservations end in 2019 due to covet
shutting down though his angel investor
Doug very kept their heads above water
once it's revealed that Margo was hired
by Tyler the Romantic dialogue sort of
has double meaning and you start to
notice when he asked Margo to put out
the cigarette we can already tell Margo
doesn't back down easily but after the
second please it sort of implied she
must as he's paying for her she
genuinely had no idea about Tyler's
obsessive booty demeanor anyone in
Tyler's life would have known that he
doesn't shut up about it hence they
weren't really in a relationship the
subtle comment of let's not ruin this by
talking price we're referring to the
cost of dinner but overall the
experience the two are having another
hint Margo's philosophy of buyers in the
consumers foreshadowing her job Bingo
Tyler's saying no one would ever call
her the girl next door because she's
strong willful of tenacity and doesn't
rattle easily but could also be a nod to
her entire not really being in a
romantic relationship when Tyler says
he's the one that's paying you think
it's the meal and it ain't and I hate
him when he says this all this may sound
a bit we're taking a boat to an island
for a meal but the inspiration came from
one of the writers will Tracy who went
to a restaurant off the coast of Norway
though the movie's location is sort of
fictional it was shot near Savannah
Georgia most three-star Michelin
restaurants are in cold rainy
dramatically seasonal environments so it
was actually meant to shoot in Scotland
but due to covid they settled in
restructuring this part of Georgia in
the story though it's based on a
restaurant in Seattle Washington stand
up
they mentioned de laurenti's an Italian
food and wine shop at Pike's Place
Market that I've been to a ton of times
shooting in Georgia during that time of
year the humidity was off the charts so
everyone was boiling during the man's
Folly scene and they had to keep
shooting away the insects and creatures
of the night before each course you see
the next course being made this was done
in part so you can see and be a part of
how they were playing in the evening
Tyler mentions watching every episode of
Chef's Table two or three times along
with Chef slow Wicks 20 times which if
you don't know is a show where they take
a look into the lives of the world's
most renowned chefs one of which was the
menu Consulting Chef Dominic kren Ray
fine said he watched her episode to
better prepare for this role
additionally the chef's table creator
David Gelb assisted as the second unit
director his job was to film Hawthorne
in the same style as the earlier shows
but Bradley did not receive was crafted
by the Tehachapi grain project which is
an actual real place they grow the
grains out here in California and
unfortunately that's it for my menu
breakdown I have only so much time but
if you want more Easter eggs more
analysis let us know in the comments
there's a ton I couldn't fit in here but
I can give it to you later in a part two
but me on Instagram and Twitter at Lulu
underscore Clements follow a new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching and remember
[Music]